these are the rapid tests they are
super simple no frills you just
swab your nose and uh you put the swab
into a buffer
and you put the buffer on the test so we
can use these right now if you want yeah
and we can try it out and all the tests
we're talking about
they're usually swabbing the nose
like that's the that's still that yeah
there are some saliva tests coming about
and they these can all work potentially
with saliva they just have to be
recalibrated
but these these swabs are really not bad
this isn't the
the deep swab that goes like way back uh
into your nose or anything this is just
the
uh just a swab that you do yourself like
right in the front of your nose
um so if you want to do it yeah do you
mind if i sure yeah
yeah why don't we start with this one
because this is uh this is abbott's
binex now test and it's really it's
pretty simple
this is this the swab from the abba test
that's correct that's
the swab from the abbott test so what
i'm going to do to start
is i'm going to take this buffer here
which is
uh this is just the buffer that goes on
to this test so this is a brand new one
i just opened this
this test out i'm gonna just take six
drops of this buffer
and put it right onto this test here
two three four five six
okay and now you're gonna take that swab
open it up
yep and now just wipe it around inside
the into the front of your nose
do a few circles uh on each nostril
looks good
this always makes me want to sneeze yeah
okay now i'm gonna have you do it
yourself um
i'm getting emotional hold it parallel
to the test so put the test down on the
table yep and then go into that bottom
hole
yep and push forward so you can start to
see it in the other hole
there you go now turn if it's once it
hits up against the top
just turn it three times one two three
and sort of
yep and now you just close so pull off
that adhesive
sticker there and now you just close the
whole thing
and and that's it that's it
now what we will see uh
is we will see a line form
what's happening now is the the buffer
that you put in there
is uh now uh moving up onto the paper
strip test and it has the material from
the swab in there
and so what we'll see is a line will
form and that's going to be the control
line and then we'll also see
uh the the ideally we'll see no line for
the actual test line
and that's because you should be
negative so one line will be positive
and
two lines will be negative that's very
cool there's this uh purple thing
creeping up
onto the control line that's perfect
that's what you want to be seeing
so you want to see that um so right now
you you essentially want to see
that that blue line turns pink or
purpley
color there's a blue line that's already
there printed
uh it should turn sort of a purple pink
color
and ideally there will be no additional
line
for the sample
and if there is that's the 99 point
whatever percent accuracy on that means
i
have i'm contagious that would mean that
you're likely contagious or you likely
have uh
infectious virus in you what we can do
because
one of the things that um that my plan
calls for
is because sometimes these tests can get
false positive results it's rare
maybe one percent or in the case of this
binex now this abbott test
point one percent so one in a thousand
one five hundred something like that can
be falsely positive
what i recommend is that when somebody
is uh
positive on one of these you turn around
and you immediately test
on a different test you could either do
it on the same but for for as good
measure
you want to use a separate test that
is somewhat orthogonal meaning that it
shouldn't turn falsely positive
for the same reason this particular test
here
this detect test because it is looking
for the rna
and not the antigen this is an amazingly
accurate test and it's sort of a perfect
gold standard or confirmatory test for
any of these antigen tests so
one of the recommendations that i've had
especially if people start using
antigen tests before you get onto a
plane uh or you know as what i call
entrance screening if somebody's
positive
you don't immediately tell them you're
positive go isolate for 10 days
you tell them let's confirm on one of
these on a detect test
that is a because it's completely
orthogonal
it's looking for the rna instead of the
antigen
there's no reason no biological reason
that both of these should be falsely
positive
so if one's falsely positive and the
other one is negative
especially because this one's more
sensitive
then i would trust this as a
confirmatory test if this one's negative
then
the antigen test you know would be
considered falsely positive it does look
like there's only a single line so this
is very exciting news
that's right yep it says wait 15 minutes
to see
both lines but in general if somebody's
really going to be positive
that line starts showing up within a
minute or two um
so you want to keep the whole we'll keep
watching it for the whole 15 minutes as
it's sitting there but
i would say you're knowing that you've
had pcr tests recently
and all that you know the odds are
pretty good odds are very packaging very
iphone like i'm i'm i'm digging the sexy
packaging
i'm a sucker for good packaging okay
you